making nice squeezing moves boy he sure
seems like he's in control now
dominating that night right and so now
I'm expecting him to take advantage of
the opportunity to trade off his Bishop
that's perhaps not so
effective how's going to stop that Aon
right well the first thing I would like
to do is
UN would would be to um my my queen is
anchored to this H6 Pawn so the first
thing I would like to do is just to put
my Pawn on
F6 and then play Queen F6 and Rook A8
well it looks like the game is actually
over oh my goodness so did what what
happened I think got a w yeah you would
think because maybe that that just
looked impossible to defend that with
that Aon rushing down the board and also
some tactical ideas here right like the
queen can post itself on F6 and then
you're going to be forced back to C8
precisely and your queen is completely
pinned down on f8 basically you can't
move anything and then we at our Leisure
play 8485 and and Away you go and
eventually uh disaster occurs and indeed
the game was a victory for gakamsky
Lenderman after the time control F in
the tow and fantastic win by got kmky as
Maurice and pointed out and as we looked
at earlier um ksky had a cleaner way
away but it was still an impressive
display and I think he's going to be
pretty satisfied with his victory he
might have to reverse his words of
before
like a new US champion yeah although
he's still probably going to be half a
point well there's a good chance he's
going to be half a point behind aian
with aian winning yeah if aian manages
to squeeze this out against Ray yeah
then he'll have five points a half a
point lead at plus three so but first of
all a big victory for G as he switches
places with his opponent um Alex
Lenderman Lenderman had a half a point
uh lead on him going into to this round
and now G has a half a point lead over
Lenderman so a big victory for G he
climbs up to the moment a Ty for first
or second as we go into our free day
will'll ask God to come and join us but
a strange moment for Lenderman to resign
maybe he realized it was hopeless but
still you would you would kind of like
to expect to see uh got to prove exactly
why the the position is one it is it
would have been nice to see although
black does seem to be almost paralyzed
in this position absolutely and so we
are going to get a God is coming St
and and let's see vtic hopei in position
Once More by the way guys we should
point out that Houdini is saying that g
is up plus
37 I don't see numbers like that very
often that's that's like all the pieces
combined Queen is nine two Rooks is
already 19 and four min pieces you're
already at 31 and a bunch of Pawns so
that's uh pretty definitive it's I I
don't see that that evaluation a lot so
I I can understand why Linderman decided
it was time to throw in the towel plus
37 with plus 37 I've never seen that I I
once had a game where the where the
computer gave me uh something like a 29
Edge or something it was a very humorous
game um but by the way in the game
between akobian and and Robson uh VAR is
just playing beautifully and now he has
even not only is he a pawn up but he has
the proper Queen and Knight versus queen
and Bishop set up and not only any night
but a night that's got these beautiful
squares to land on exactly so Ray in
deep trouble as Ray on tilt actually
hasn't he just gone through um a
situation where you know a promising
start is now gone uh backwards well
actually he won he's just had a top SE
tury tournament in general but he did
defeat moner yesterday so he's kind of
just like up and down up and down a lot
games by Ray rodon and we do have our
defending Champion got kamsky um to talk
about A really lovely Victory today
against the tournament leader Alexander
Lenderman two Brooklyn guys battling and
they're with Maurice Ashley also from
Brooklyn Brooklyn's in the house all
right gakamsky who uh has just won his
game welcome to the show thank you g did
you feel that you were in control the
whole way through this game where seems
like you had a pretty smooth Victory
well not really it's the first time I
played this line so um I didn't really
know all the nuances and after black
played A3 I felt like black is even
better because um I think lerman's
mistake was he allowed the exchange of
dark Square Bishops after which the his
king became way too vulnerable to all
the tactics and after that white
probably has an advantage but if he
played something like Rook E8 and
allowed the bishop to stay in the game
then I'm sure that even black is better
yeah but after that uh it was very
complex and almost blundered this nice
trick here I just wanted to show you um
when he played Queen f8 briefly I just
wanted to take the Knight on
D4 and then I missed that the black
simply takes the pawn on
A5 and if I take on A5 then it's just
Queen H6 check and uh Queen
D2 and black is winning so I'm doing
doing quite well here did you did your
hard skip a beat when you saw this
tactic yeah I was I actually raised my
hand to play this move and then I just
realized uh that this is losing and I
was like thank God you
know okay yeah those those uh defensive
tactical instincts took over in this
moment uh afterwards we said he resigned
uh clearly he's he's much worse in the
final position if you may just uh go to
the board please for us uh he resigned
at this moment a lot of folks in our
audience are not world class Grand
Masters explain to us why it is that
this was a very good time for him to
stop thews well his quen is titled the
defense of these two squares G7 and F7
Pawn so basically the only way he plays
with his Rook on C6 but once White Queen
goes to F6 there becomes a threat to
play Rook A8 and um you know try to get
rid of that defender on of the G7 so
let's uh make a move for him like Rook
to C4 right so Queen F6 and now I want
to play Rook A8 so he's forced to go
back and now the pawn just simply goes
to A7 then Rook goes to B7 B8 and it's
winning so let's uh play a couple of
moves just because black is actually
helpless to do anything about it so make
a couple of moves and and Rook B7 and
off for a trade A7 and finally we
deflect the queen from f8 Square and
then you just go down and
yeah and that's going to be it yes but
actually it wasn't that clear right
after the um the time control because
after I played Rook D3 on the first he
just took on B5 and I felt that he
allowed me way too much he should have
played really actively like Rook C2 here
and uh there's still a lot of um play
left so you know in a way I got like it
today so we often say luck goes to the
strong so he still has to find the moves
well you're now at the moment in first
place it's not a position you've been in
throughout the championship although
it's a comfortable position for you
having been here so many times already
what are your thoughts about your play
before the rest
day well it's quite shaky I don't see a
lot of tactics so I'm trying to play a
super solid chess and not to give my
opponents any chance to you know to have
an edge at all but that kind of play
actually is very risky because um there
are some opponents like curu for example
he just wins every game because of his
risky style and wild tactics and that's
a big risk fortunately in this
tournament there are not that many sharp
players I mean only grave and um maybe
some of the younger guys you know
they're really tactically um Masters but
um you know it's it's an approach what
can I do well early in the tournament I
think it was two rounds ago you said you
think you're going to see we're going to
see a new champion at this event we were
very shocked by that especially
considering your history in the event
now you're in Pole Position you look
like the the one people are chasing do
you still feel that way about this this
uh final three rounds well I feel now
like uh my hopes been raised a little
bit but based on my play here I wouldn't
say I would deserve anything like that
so I'm just playing every game and see
see how it goes all right well thanks
for joining us and good luck in the rest
of your games thank you four time time
champion gakamsky at the moment in the
lead in the tournament of course if
akobian wins he'll LeapFrog him uh and
there's still a lot of play left here at
the Championships back to you guys a lot
of times I've made a I'm about to make a
move and sometimes I recognize it's the
blunder but I I really remember the
times that I made a move and then
instantly recognized it was a blender so
that Knight takes D4 Knight takes E5 got
had must have a seventh sent or
something to realize that just as the
moment he's going to a seventh sense you
know just at the moment he's ready to
take the D4 Pawn he he just at the last
second he he sees Knight E5 he plays
something else wins a terrific game I
mean I have those feelings that I'm the
guy who's making the move and then you
know like just almost by the time I
press my clock I realized oh no I've
overlooked something you know that that
that horrible feeling you have like a
cold shower as it just freezes you so
that is a terrible feeling it's terrible
we've got some news in the Women's
Championship and you know Anna Zoni and
bah Sky Team we checked it on on them
and on them right around time control
and it looked like it was drawish but
that Camila had the better position Ed
small Edge yeah um and you didn't think
it was much and that we were probably
steered toward to draw but all of a
sudden I'm looking at this position and
White's a up how did that
happen can keep the pawn well there it
well it depends on who it is to move but
if it was black white to move white
could just play Knight D6 and just trade
pawns so yes she can keep the pawn but
it's still it's probably draw but let's
go back actually Anna did play D6 okay
let's just go back to understanding so
we got about here and we both felt that
uh Camila was doing fine um I thought
the game was probably likely to be a
draw we get a position like this and how
did Anna manage to win a pawn what a
crafty
lady oh she has over she hasn't realized
that her G Pawn was far more vulnerable
than White's age pawn and we do have I
think we're up to date with the current
position no we're not I apologize we're
getting there s shortly and this is our
position where you where D6 has been
played yes and then Kima has already
responded with Rook to D5 okay so I'm
guessing that uh King
F4 I'm trying to Sid step this action
here Rook B3 Rook D3 check um still it
looks
pretty it looks closer to a draw than
anything I'm thinking Knight D4 with uh
pay attention there is a a fork in the
position and and this Rook is actually
pretty good behind this
Pawn that's where they belong right
right uh but Anna she did your king T
right Anna trying to press upon PA ahead
and that would be a huge result because
we thought Arena was going to be
cruising to Victory Anna making a draw
Anna would be a half a point behind if
Anna were to win this game and Arena
draws then at the going in to the rest
day it's Anna with a half-point lead who
that I although Arena um Alyssa's just
completely in the tag after King to G1
um trying to figure out whether to play
perhaps Queen to E3 check or queen G3 if
there's any way to get her Bishop in
she's been thinking for I think about 20
minutes here in the game between Arena
crash I brought it up on my board
um yeah I don't see how and just as I
said that she made a move she actually
played not Queen E3 check not Queen G3
check but Queen to G4 check Queen to G4
check very
good not too much of a change here
although it's nice to pick up a palm
with check Maurice you have some
insights to
share well in your game I was following
that game and it turns out that
according to Houdini the position is
just a draw she can't really do anything
can um Alyssa in order to make progress
in the position so she's just going to
have to repeat moves and Hope that
there's a blunder somehow by Arena but
in another game that's crucial for the
Championships akobian definitely had an
edge in his game but it looks like Ray
Robson has allowed that edge to increase
dramatically take a look at this
position there's no question a cobian's
up a pawn it is a pawn but it is this
Pawn after all and it's not passed yet
it's going to take some time for the
queen and Knight to harmonize themselves
and figure out how to win the game here
Ray should have played the move Queen to
A8 check and then bring the queen back
and challenge this formation if
especially if the Knight drops back
challenge Black's pieces to figure out
how to move forward instead he played a
really bad move he played the move Queen
to C3 and suddenly this Knight got the
square it wanted after all it could it
could have been back here on f8 or it
could be being pinned back here on G6
but now it's on F4 and then he continued
it and compounded his Mistake by going
passive with this bishop thinking he
needed to keep this pieace but right now
aobi and has a monster move Queen down
to D1 and White's pieces are getting
frozen out of the game threat number one
Knight to E2 check big time you can't
move your king because your Bishop is in
need of Defense so he's this piece is
frozen this piece is Frozen the only
piece to move around is the queen but
where do you put it with the threat if
this move Queen to E3 you want to see a
fine move here G5 cementing the Knight
on the Square and now we have what looks
to me as like some kind of zong what can
you do there's no move to make you can't
move the bishop you can't move the queen
you could push the pawn but actually if
you push the pawn and drops this Pawn
you can't move these guys you lose them
where do you put the queen if you move
the queen anywhere of course then this
Pawn drops with check so suddenly white
has no move after this without losing
something in the in the position going
down yet a second Pawn Black's position
looks dominant now it looks like a
cobian's task has been simplified and he
did play the move Queen to D1 and the
the move uh check is on the board King
H7 Ray looks disgusted right now and
akobian looks all of cool purposeful
collected and determined it looks like
he's going to win this game and move
ahead and take the sole lead here at the
Championships guys that's great to see
veran coming of course I'm a Robson fan
as well but when I think about veran I
think professional M you know he's he's
he just every time he plays you know he
just gives off that vibe that you know
we like chess players to to give you
know just he works hard he's um
determined he's determined and um yeah
although he hasn't won a championship
boy it's uh something that he would
really really like I'm looking at Ray's
U race just seems so despondent at the
moment and no doubt I don't know whether
it was a zuk's or not no doubt though
when uh VAR established his KN on F4 the
handwriting is on the wall that Knight
is suddenly dominating the bishop and
he's a pawn ahead so I do expect him for
sure to collect the full point and to go
into the in into uh the rest day with
the
lead that's right very uh big turn of
events here at the championship remember
we had Lenderman leading by a full point
just a couple rounds ago it seems like
an eternity you know
well we knew that Alex is going to have
a big challenge for him playing Black
against gakamsky and Alexander onook
back to back uh he forgot we forgot to
mention Sam Shanklin because Sam was the
one that really uh turned his tournament
uh upside down with a victory two losses
by Lenderman there are a lot of decisive
results in this Championship aren't
there aronberg m mner was actually the
only draw of the day so far we've got
three decisive results it does look like
a gray of onook is dur for a draw that
game's been going on for quite a while
we got highly simplified position we got
so excited by the ladies uh uh time
trouble as I look at it it's a a rook
ending two versus two however uh these
are not the happiest of Pawns on H7 and
H6 um still I believe that um Rook if
you took the H S Pawn away I believe the
game is still a draw um in these Rook
endings so let's just go back uh a few
moves because it's well not too much
happened did it kind of nice technique
by there by Ona Shook at the end that
Rook is kind of stopping the king from
going forward so nice lateral defense
who you're going back with a couple well
I just wanted I was just so very curious
how they got it and so they got into to
a rook ending that got all the way down
here and
Alex was
able to get rook and two versus rook and
two no this is fine this is going to be
a draw I'm pretty confident about that
one so so we've got uh what we've got
left are basically critical games in the
championship we've got Arena Crush Anna
zatonski and it does look like both of
those games might end up being draws in
which case they would be tied for the
lead the only difference would be that t
would now be a half Point behind instead
of a full point behind right she's
gained she gained on the leaders and
although she didn't want to talk about
it TAF has a nice schedule relative to
the field of course mikina uh surprising
Arena Crush in this round could easily
surprise her as well but yeah you got to
say on paper that she has a chance uh
for the overall Championship as well the
the wooden champ the chion US Women's
Champion and the world championship one
of these days one of these days First We
Take St Louis then we take the world oh
we are the capital of Justin America
well that's where you got to start so
gray have headed for a draw yes crushi
and zatonski seems like a high
possibility that those games will be
drawn too and then aov in firmly in the
driver's seat precisely so it'll be
interesting we'll have at least one
clear leader probably at the end of
today right veran aobi in the US
Championship very exciting as I
mentioned on earlier shows rusan comes
to the chess club he's one of the cast
of rotating grandm so you can check out
his lessons on the St Louis chess club's
YouTube channel right his lectures are
being archived as well yes and it's
absolutely an amazing Channel I mean
people are talking about it all the time
because hey it's free chess lessons
right I have to share with you while
during one of the breaks I went upstairs
and and I ran into a mom whose children
play chess and her son has a little
tablet and at night when the sun's going
to bed it's supposed to be in bed
sleeping he's got uh The Archives of
this event on his tablet and her her
mother his mother says to me that she
hears the voices of Maurice Jennifer and
myself coming underneath the covers as
her little son is following our analysis
so I was kind of warmed by that story
it's How Sweet It Is oh that is sweet
and we've got a hundreds of videos here
in the chess club and glassic center of
St Louis including some replays of not
only this year's us Championship but
last year's sinkfield Cup right and
we've also got almost two million views
so just an amazing YouTube channel
definitely check it out um I also want
to take this opportunity to point out
some of our comments and questions one
that I really liked which I didn't get a
chance to to earlier in the broadcast
was about Walter Brown six time US
champion also a friend of yours
mentioned him several times um the
question was does he still play actively
I'm going to try to find the person who
asked that um but yeah I noticed he
actually just played in a tournament in
Iceland right and rovic he played quite
well in fact uh he just released his uh
biopic uh the stress of Chess uh Walter
Brown was for me one of the real real
hard opponents I had uh when I was
coming up in the 70s literally Walter
was uh not only the king of the US
championships six of which he won but it
the king of the open tournaments as well
he just won every single open tournament
from the national open US Open American
open he was really formidable competitor
and I've never ever played an opponent
perhaps only with the exception of Gary
Kasparov who worked so hard at the board
oh yeah his energy I mean he got into a
lot of time pressure as well oh yes talk
about time travel scram he was
incredible to watch Good Luck taking on
the nidorf against him yeah um so and
that that question was from chess nerd
chess nerd there's no chess nerds I
don't believe that there no nerds and
chess Walter Brown also created this new
chess game finesse um yeah he's just a
really interesting dude and uh thanks
for the question big poker player too
that's right he also plays poker plays
poker and chess he's 65 he's still going
strong that's what we want all you guys
to do out there it's not just about the
kids it's about the older d as well and
we've got Maurice with some news on robs
and aopi and is VAR really in that
point actually his opponent is giving
him the point uh it looks like Ray in
this position in his typical time
pressure really bad time management
skills has made an even worse move here
he played a check and then Queen C4 it
was possible to take this Pawn would
check in this position but then the
Knight would have to escape back onto
the G5 Square not the greatest of
circuits for the Knight to end on so VAR
said you know what I don't need to play
that move I'm just going to play the
move G5 and Ray with only two minutes on
his clock needed to take advantage of
this one moment to play King H2 which by
the way Houdini thinks is not as bad as
all that for white bad yes should be
winning but it's not giving it minus
plus blacks all over white in this this
position clearly worse though for white
but white instead of doing that in time
pressure played this move Queen to E4
check instead after G5 Queen to E4 check
and Houdini is saying what's that about
you just left the B Pawn alone and the H
Pawn is still hanging what are you going
to do to guard both when I just back up
and wait for you and this position is
really bad now he's getting into that
zong position where he could play Queen
E3 remember and now the move King over
and this position is absolutely
miserable for white this Pawn is about
to drop he's in zong again remember that
position we showed earlier no place to
put the queen to guard both these pawns
you could snap a Pawn off here but
you're going to drop this pawn and this
one is likely to go as well and the
bishop can't move the king can't move
this Pawn if it advances will stop the
defense of this one position just looks
terrible for Ray he's in severe time
pressure I have him losing on time here
I'm sure that's not what happen happen
but uh let's get back here so he
actually still has 135 left akobian
needs to calculate right here to figure
out what to do to just get his King back
not worrying about any checks one line
actually this was a funny line the
computer showed after this check King up
like what do you do it's only move it
gives to continue the game Queen H1 you
know things are bad when you're playing
Queen
H1 obviously the B Pawn drops and
everything is horrible here but clearly
not able to defend well is the youngster
in time pressure and you talk about
despondent look at that posture that
looks like uh somebody stole his best
toy all right all right or his uh his
tennis racket
right he look very depressed right now
knowing he's about to lose this game and
darar just needs to find the Right Moves
and you know how chess players are we
don't feel feel sorry for you not at the
board anyway not at the board no bar
does not feel sorry for him and this is
also the day before rest day so it's
kind of a positive and a negative if you
lose before rest day emotionally it's
awful because you have to think about
your loss for the whole day but it's
also good in a way because you get a
chance to kind of rest and you know get
over it and get ready to start fresh a
day later true that but I was thinking
more selfishly about myself I'm ready
for a rest day Mel uh well good luck
with that because tomorrow we got a real
fun day for you community outreach
program yes we got some Girl Scouts
coming to Ballpark Village here in St
Louis before the cards game and we're
going to be doing a little human chess
match for them and then in the evening
as we mentioned earlier we've got
reunion going on across the street at
the World Chess Hall of Fame sold out
it's one of their concerts that they
have they're going they're doing a
couple concerts a month now over at the
hall of fame and wow and you can watch
it online on live stream it's going to
be a recreation the famous Duchamp cage
match and you me and Ben fold and Mar
Ashley are also going to be involved
here again are the details so you know
earlier we got that will be live
streamed as well in because all the
tickets are sold out but you can watch
it online or you could come to the
museum and see it live streamed on I
think the first floor so it's going to
be it's going to be held I or or vice
versa but you'll be able to see it live
stream um as well
possible for it to be sold out when it
says there the admission is free how
does that work it means that everybody
rsvpd and that all the RSVPs are are
taken oh looks like we and it looks like
it's a draw it's a draw it looks like
the players played a Perpetual check
yeah I noticed Lissa was drawing
something I see people do a lot like she
knew that she was she she couldn't find
a win and then she just like ran down
her time and then the incentive to go
for the draw by Perpetual becomes even
higher because now youve just run down
your time and I'm not faulting her for
it right I'm just saying once you start
seeing the player like use all of their
time go lower and lower and lower you
know they're about to take the per right
well one of the one of the classic
classic stories of all time is uh I very
rarely offer draws uh but when I did I
had a rule that if my opponent thought
for 30 minutes or long it was 100% sure
he was going to accept the draw because
you know like he starts convincing
himself he has to accept the draw so I
once play John Fedor itz grandmas the
Fed
uh I think it was VI con I'm not sure I
offered a draw from what I thought was a
very normal even position he thought
about 45 minutes declined the draw was
immediately in time trouble and lost
terribly so it's like um I don't really
like the draw offer and I do like the
Sophia roles in fact I'd be even more
aggressive and say you just have to play
you can't offer a draw uh for the first
time control of 40 moves you have to
only on move 41 but of course you can
make a Perpetual repetition no problem
but I think that uh it's not too great
an ask for the play to ask the players
to play an entire uh time control okay
what do we have remaining J just uh a
lot of results have come in there's only
a couple games remaining Robson um
akobian which we believe that a cobian's
about to reel in and then gray of onuk
which looks uh firmly headed towards a
draw and then of course our a crucial
game in the women's Championship Zoni
bah skyi where you also um last time we
checked only a couple moves have been
happened since then you also thought
that Black's a beautifully placed Rook
on D5 compensated for the pawn deficit
well let me and it looks like that one
might be further simplifying actually
with that last move by Camila was a
goodie C4 C3 running her pass Pawn up
the board her last move the Rook on D5
nicely placs what you were mentioning J
just behind keeping an eyeball on this
D6 Pawn Camila has just played the move
C3 anticipating that after Knight takes
Rook takes both pawns get eliminated and
what remains on the board Rook Knight
and two pawns versus Rook Knight and one
Pawn should
be easily drawn let's just say not
easily drawn but drawn that's right so
it might go on a little while but we
expect this one to end in a handshake
between the two friends a not not a not
a quick one though a very hardfought
game very hard not surprising U Maurice
what do you have for us uh you you're
looking at Crush mikina I am because the
win was so clear right and I was
wondering a fine Champion like aren what
happened that caused her not to win this
game so I started reviewing the position
and I'm guessing at what she missed that
caused her to not win and here's I'm
going to ask her about it when she comes
down for an interview here's the moment
in the game where she's just just
dominating and the best move the move
that puts her up according to Houdini
12.7 12.57 that's a queen plus a bishop
at least right huge Advantage uh was
Queen takes C5 anything less anything
else is way down the scale at 3.78 which
is about a piece more than a piece
winning also but in this moment the move
Queen C5 just it's like thanks for the
piece she has two Rooks on the board
Queen and and Bishop clearly uper rook
in the moment but there is one move to
worry about the move Knight takes F3
check and if you look at this move a bit
more carefully you realize that uh
Bishop F3 there's the ghost of a
Perpetual here Queen check and it's more
than a ghost in fact because after the
king moves there's Rook H3
check and now if you take suddenly Queen
takes with check and how do you escape
this barrage of checks so it looks
almost like it's perpetual here but but
the problem is this after
after where were we here Queen C7 check
King F6 this moment after Queen takes C5
Knight takes F3 check all she had to do
now and she had to see and I say all she
had to do she was in terrific time
pressure all she had to do was just back
her King up to H1 now there the black
king is under heavy fire will fall apart
very quickly but he or she might have
thought wait a minute am I not getting M
and it's no you're not because Queen G1
is not mate because of the rescue from
the other Queen so when you're in time
pressure ghosts start to go in your head
you start to see variations you're not
sure and you miss something that you
would not have missed if you had all the
time in the world on the clock so she
had to just see Queen takes on C5 that
would have been the easy move
demolishing her opponent but all those
possible tricks and fine nuances she had
to find she did not see and ended up
only drawing this game a game she will
be kicking herself about for a while to
come guys but again and again and again
it was the time trouble that tripped uh
her up she was lucky yesterday did did
it really happen Jennifer did her clock
really ticked down to 1 second I think
that was today's game actually I think
yesterday that's what I mean yesterday
it was like five we'll find out because
she's getting set up with an interview I
find that just so shocking because at
that moment a crazy thing could happen a
lamp could fall over something you get
distracted for a mere second and you'd
end up losing so that was
really extraordinary if true that she
got so low on the
clock well yes we are getting set up
with Irena and we'll also have Alysa
with us in just a few minutes um you
want to check on Robson aobi in while
we're getting hered up
absolutely that was our second G so
Robson playing B4 in this position it's
just I think that's a Desperado
Desperado yeah he just it's kind of a
zuk Zang type of position he's running
out of really reasonable moves to play
so B3 B4 but I think that uh VAR is well
on his way to tidying things up and this
game is in the bag all right well
that'll be uh it'll be interesting to
see uh what VAR has to say about his
spectacular streak I mean three in a row
in a tournament this strong is nothing
to sneeze at probably the simplest move
by the way Knight D is just simply
Knight D5 that way you centralize the
Knight no Perpetual checks you attack
the GU Queen you're ready to play ab and
then simply run your Pawn home this kind
of feels like the reverse of gotsky
versus Slender right exactly and we do
have our defending Champion Irena Crush
about her draw today gave us a lot of
excitement but I'm sure she wasn't so
thrilled and she's with Maurice Ashley
indeed with Grandmaster Arena Crush
after a wild game a game it looked like
first she had some compensation then
suddenly you were under complete control
and winning and then in the critical
moment things went wrong what
happened well I made a a bunch of
horrible moves in a row in this winning
position just couldn't uh uh yeah
calculate anything I mean I was winning
in so many different ways look every
single like 10 moves in a row win um but
yeah I I really um did my trademark uh
collapsed with you know a lot of extra
material and I was lucky you know that I
wasn't even losing with after that
horrible play so there was a critical
moment that I guessed atth right here
where you could have taken the bishop on
C5 and you would have been up did you
see this move Queen C5 in time pressure
or yeah of course I saw it I mean I was
I was just kind of concerned about this
queen G3 Queen E1 cuz Nyon no longer
have anything covering the back Rank and
you know in time trouble it's not that
easy easy to see King H1 I mean I guess
it's not that hard either um but uh well
it is giving back a rook giving back a
rook with check and not recapturing so
psychologically it's kind of hard to see
that in your calculation when you you
know you've only got some kind of
seconds for for this calculation you
were down to one second on the clock did
that really happen yeah at some point
well I was moving when it was two
seconds but you know uh to it takes a
little time to move so when I finally
completed my move and pressed the clock
it was 1 second when did you feel like
you had just blown it at what point did
you feel like it it just had gone I mean
after Queen d8 Bishop E7 I was planning
Queen h8 here which I see is winning and
that was had been kind of the idea but
um I missed everything you know I missed
Rook H3 obviously at this point I wasn't
really calculating very much um I just
wasn't sure what I was going to do after
Queen h8 and like King F5 probably steps
into Bishop E4 I really should have I
should have done that check that's what
I was planning I mhm you you made a a
statement you said uh you did your
trademark go ahead a lot of material and
then not win the game yeah how why do
you say that well it's happened to me a
couple of times in the past this not the
first time I had a game once with
Gustafson I was like up a piece and I
sort sort of a collaps in time pressure
um so you know it's not like I do this
all the time but it's definitely um not
uncommon that I would mess up and
precisely this way you know completely
winning position and just mess up in
time trouble so how do you get your head
clear after such a game you do have a
rest day uh to think about it but
sometimes that can make things worse
maybe not get a good night's sleep how
do you recover from from this at least
you didn't lose the game it yeah how
fortunate you don't seem too happy right
now I'm not happy because I you know I
think I played really horribly um I mean
the whole game actually I didn't have a
very good feeling about this game I
don't really like the way I played the
opening either and I did think that
black had very good compensation if we
just go a little bit higher over here
how do we do that agrees by the way
there are I mean I don't like the way I
played um this position this was one
very interesting moment right here in
the opening um W okay the computer
thinks this is okay for black I was
looking at this interesting move B
before here I thought this was a
critical position that we got upon
emerging from the opening before trying
to destroy those pawns and I liked
everything here for white except the
move
C4 and yes the computer seems to agree
so at least I spotted that um the idea
is the bishop is developing with check
to B4 and black is going to Castle
quickly and um yeah yeah well look at
that it's not it's even worse for white
and that's actually I spent a lot of
time trying to evaluate the move B4 um
so yeah the way I played this position I
think B3 Bishop B7 yeah right here I
think black has you know really
excellent compensation that was my
feeling during the game and in fact if I
was playing Robson I'm sure there would
have been some exchange sack we did know
that exchange sacrifice on F3 looks very
powerful was always there I mean even
here I don't think like I don't know if
it's necessarily the best move but even
here like a move like Rook takes F3 with
the idea of like Queen f8 is giving
black some play it's exactly what we
noted in our analysis as well uh even
though the Houdini doesn't suggest it
it's a natural thing it's okay to play
queen f8 and I have to go back to um
Bishop E2 this the only way to defend
this pawn and it's not an easy position
for white to play I mean I was just
happy that I wasn't uh losing
immediately here but I don't really like
it yes there's this plan Knight D5
Knight F4 just simple simple play for
black he's got great pieces great
structure how did you end up in this
line though you isn't it your
preparation you the bloomenfeld is a is
not something that you've never seen
before right uh let's just say my
preparation could have been better for
this game because um obviously I didn't
have any idea what I was doing in the
opening so uh so you know yeah like she
the way she played she made some
reasonable moves and I made this move
just so that my knight would be
supported uh Knight D5 was good and Rook
C1 I think this was a good practical
move I don't know um it's not it's
somewhere in the number three on the
computer's list the thing is I was even
afraid of Rook takes A4 exchange sacks
here and Knight C3 and just take and
again ruin my structure so the idea of
this move is that if there's Rook A4
I'll sack back the exchange instead of
losing my light squared Bishop on E2 um
but she made this really H5 by the way
is I think a good inclusion for black
yes as computer points out but Knight F4
I really didn't think this was a good
move the computer seems to think it's
okay I didn't think um I think it was
letting me off a little bit easy in this
position I was for the first time in the
game I was starting to feel optimistic
here because you know I got got to
Castle I still have an intact structure
um Queen f8 yes I was looking at that
move that was my top move for black but
G5 was a bit much on her part still okay
but was starting to stretch the position
a little bit that's really funny I mean
all of these evaluations I got to say
after G5 I thought I was just
winning so look at that um evaluation I
mean I don't know I thought 91 was a was
a good move and I really thought that
Black's position would collapse here
really fast um but she made some good
moves here and I uh Queen f8 was good
knight D3 Rook H4 yeah and over here I
just wasn't quite precise enough um to
be honest I just missed a simple move
Bishop
D5 and I had somehow been looking at
Queen H6 to defend that pawn bishop D5
um and now there's the idea of Rook
takes A4 and C4 so I just placed the
bishop really well and I really think
she should have so that's why I made
this desperate move F4 because after
something like H3 which had been let's
say the plan let's say we play Rook
takes
A4 and that exchange sacks always in the
air and C4 this was looking um you know
Knight takes E5 is coming and it was
looking really dangerous white so
clearly you weren't on your game today I
mean you it seemed like you missed quite
a few moves uh you must have been in
this situation before though one bad
game doesn't the tournament make so
again what do you do so that you close
this out strong three rounds to go well
I'm thrilled to get a rest day honestly
I wasn't feeling that great before this
game like I maybe I didn't sleep so well
but my neck hurts a lot and I can barely
like turn my head without any pain so
I'm thinking of getting a massage
tomorrow I think that'll be a good
investment um yeah I mean yeah just you
know sometimes you just get up and you
don't feel great you know and I gotta
say so I had some premonition that this
game um would not be so easy for me and
it was you know it was worse than I
thought but even during the game I mean
honestly it was a difficult position to
play I wasn't happy with the opening and
um I felt lucky to be able to crawl out
of it and uh start to make some
improvements um but yeah the collapse
and time pressure um
that um not too surprising that happens
to me once in a while and I just I'll
try just try to play better the next
three games I can see the game is still
playing with your mind hopefully that
massage changes things quite a bit
tomorrow and it sounds like a good idea
thanks for joining us we wish you the
best in the rest of the tournament thank
you moris grandm Arena Crush after a
very difficult fight managing to survive
all the complications yes uh massage
what do you think about that for us on
the I'm in I'm in figure me in I think
that's our next bet I still got to get
your your
sushi upping the stakes upping the
stakes what do we have left on uh I
think vars cruising for
yeah I kind of feel like the only reason
robson's continuing you to play is cuz
he's so low on time that he's hoping
that
he'll opponent to make a a blender or
that just he or just that he barely has
enough time to see how bad it is you
know he might as well just play a few
more moves right or the old kits I
didn't have enough time to
resign well he could just play um Queen
to eight Queen takes H6 in this position
so it was just played in fact so we we
grabbed another PA he did indeed but
white has managed to regain it with
Queen E5 Queen F4 queen h8 king E7 and
now Queen takes H6 and everything looks
totally off sides for right and you just
want to start running with the a pawn
right absolutely and no checks at all
the King on E7 just is a in a perfect
position to guard against every check
absolutely no the king uh boy it's
actually even hard to imagine what okay
you make one check your queen goes to B
D7 but what would actually even be a
second check after like King F6 so no
Black's King is is is beautiful and in
the meantime is a pawns running for a
touchdown so I do think that uh Ray is
looking for the right moment to give it
a rest that's right and we do have uh
and that's going to be huge for our
tournament of course fian will be the
new leader in the US Chess Championship
after this win absolutely and we've got
Alyssa mikina about her draw against Ena
crush with the black pieces certainly
before the game she'd be happy with that
result but it was so for the opportunity
she had a lot of opportunities to lose
but even some to win ex As Time control
approached and uh she's with uh Maurice
to talk about that roller
coaster indeed we are with FM Alysa
Melina thanks for joining us on the show
H thanks again for having me that was
crazy I mean her time pressure you were
throwing pieces at her somehow she
missed a win what were your impressions
just at that point in the time pressure
right around move 35 yeah this was one
of the craziest games I've played I I
sacked an exchange right when she was in
time pressure and I don't think it was
that sound she of course had several
opportunities to refute it but I was
playing off of her time and at one point
she got down to one second on the clock
uh so it in that sense it
worked now when somebody's that close I
mean you're are you thinking she's going
to flag are you thinking let me not pay
attention to that I mean I've never seen
anyone flag with the 30C increment um
but you you can't let those thoughts get
in your head because of course I'm
playing the top seed she's leading the
tournament I'm with the black pieces I
feel like I'm winning but all all these
thoughts are harmful you know I I just
have to play the position and at one
point it they kind of crept into my head
and I thought that I did have a win
there at at the very end when I took on
H3 right at time control that was
another tough exchange sacrifice to make
but I thought I would have Queen E3
check there which was forcing and then I
would get the two yes we did have that
position but first of all can we just
take a look at this position uh here she
played Queen to Da check but she had an
opportunity to just take your Bishop in
this position did you see this if you
don't mind pressing me very sure did you
see this line at all you did you think
you were still controlling the game well
right well here you know I would have to
take right but she can just go back with
her king that's the move she missed
that's the move that I missed too
because I thought after take I I can go
Queen G3 and then I'm fine and get the
draw okay so both of you in heavy time
pressure miss this this Nuance uh after
that though you play the spectacular
line Rook takes H3 you want to take us
to that position just uh press press the
press the the side the bar up a little
yeah there you go and just the moment
you play well here I thought um like she
could go Queen HH check after Bishop B7
so that was I was really surprised that
she just went back and then she gave my
king safety right so okay yeah and then
we'll fast forward to this point where I
took on H3 yeah did you see Rook H3
coming I mean you had only two minutes
left on the
clock I did I I saw it and you know it's
tough to play a move like that
especially at time control you have an
Impulse to go Queen G3 check and you
know get to the time control and then
have the 30 minutes to think but I saw
that RI takes H3 was forcing I saw that
I could at least have a Perpetual there
and then in time control I thought that
um
after after
this I could go Queen E3 check
here right she'd have to trade Queen
yeah this is what I saw back on move 39
and then I thought that oh okay you know
these are unstoppable but there's
actually several ways she can draw here
she saw King G2 I I saw King F1 later
when I was calculating
and this rook and king it's not just
beating the Rook it's the rook and king
together plus your Pawn is the wrong PA
and I thought that I could go Bishop H4
here right so I'm threatening E2 and it
looks again like my pawns are
unstoppable but then I saw this
incredible Rook e one move and yaser
called himself stupid for not seeing
rookie one right away by the way but I
thought this was a good move I'm glad
you said incredible agreeing well it's
it's an incredible save in this position
it turns out that you know if I take the
Rook then I'm actually losing because I
can't catch the Pawns in time and so I
was calculating lines where I could win
this H3 Pawn but it turns out that this
Pawn is too slow because that pawn
queens and it controls the H1 Square so
I I just I I couldn't see a win at that
point and but I went for the Perpetual
in the end this is two crazy games you
had in two days yesterday it looks like
you were winning against byin skite why
is it so hard to win games at the the
Championships I I think it it's
definitely a problem for me converting
advantages that's always been a problem
especially for these past few years when
when I'm resting and I'm in law school
and I'm not playing a lot it's not that
I'm not studying but it's just hard to
you know find that like final punch that
will convert the game and I I was happy
with my play in the opening I know at
one point I kind of you know gii maybe
that was pushing it a bit but I I felt
like I got a really good position and I
was um know making good
moves so yeah I mean at the US
championships people fight back you know
no no one's just going to roll over um
in my game against the Sher you know it
was also desperate position I fought
tooth and nail to try and save that
against the young 13-year-old you have
three rounds to go but you get a rest
day tomorrow Arena says she's going to
get a massage probably what's your plan
for tomorrow you know that doesn't sound
like a bad idea yeah Yes sounds like
there's a massage party going on guys
maybe but you know yesterday my game
went up to 111 11 move so it's just such
a tough long game and this game instead
of focusing on Preparation which was
what I've been doing every round I just
slept in today because I I realized that
this tournament is so much more about
stamina than about catching your
opponent and prep you know I've never
had a game where my opponent just went
into my prep and I didn't expect her to
go into the bloomenfeld I know she
didn't expect me to play the bloomenfeld
I've never played it before so this game
was all about you know stamina and
making decisions at those critical
moments indeed well we hope uh you get a
rest day and and maybe you and Arena
will be be off uh together at the spa
and uh and get ready for the final three
rounds yes thank you all right best of
luck uh Alyssa Melina with a terrific
fight certainly kept us
entertained the Championships are truly
heating up and have entered the stretch
run guys nice nice I mean I she saw a
lot in the game and she had a very good
practical approach that if your
opponent's in time trouble and you see
some risky variations where you're will
willing to take risks uh but you're
you're putting your opponent King under
threat um you go for it and this idea
that Arena actually went down to 1
second I mean that's ridiculous that's
just ridiculous I mean you could lose I
mean you could you the peace could trip
up there there's like a thousand Reasons
that you should never ever ever do this
this is like so if I were her second it
would be like bad Arena bad Arena don't
do that again plus she's giving her
second a heart attack when you have 30
second increment yeah that's uh getting
down to one no don't do that unless
you're losing but uh Ray Robson and uh
verin kovan are still playing and
meanwhile gra have and onuk is trying to
demonstrate the filor position for us on
the board I think ever since that 14th
move draw gra must you know he feels a
little guilty he wants to really really
play King vers King right so this of
course is um an opening that owners
probably learned when he was seven years
old the drawing technique in this
position exactly the drawing technique
is very simple uh Alex onuk just simply
keeps his Rook on the sixth rank white
would play uh I think it's a black to
move white would uh as soon as white
advances his Pawn to the F6 Square so
that his next turn he's threatening to
play King G6 and Rook B8 mate as soon as
the pawn is on the F6 Square then you go
down and you harass White's King from
behind with a whole series of checks and
famously called the filor defense or the
fidor technique because denk and fidor
from the 17th century wrote about it in
his book uh chess play and now the
interesting thing for those of you
watching I know we say oh you learned it
when he was seven but of course I'm
saying that uh partly factiously I mean
obviously Onish shuk is a a great player
so when he started learning at a young
age this is literally the first or
second basic endings basic endings yeah
but um it's not that obvious if you
don't know it a lot of people try to
play Rook A1 and check with the Rook
before the pawn goes up and it has been
a draw but um that of course is not as
strong because then if you if you uh
move your Rook away
before uh White occupies the F6 Square
then the problem that you run into is
that after King G6 Rook behind check
King F6 the King has F found Shelter
From the checks that's why you have to
wait right and often some of these
positions are drawing too but obviously
a lot more difficult than just putting
your Rook on the sixth rank very much so
and I do see that Alex marlor uh the
club manager here right who assistant
Arbiter in the is collecting score
sheets the two players have agreed to a
draw that's and the Robson game is also
over and I'm uh guessing that Robson has
resigned yes after um a move Queen C1
check if you want to bring up the final
position sure
absolutely so a big victory another big
victory I should say for verian akobian
as he surges into the leag
on the strength of three victories in a
row back to back to back that's the way
uhhuh
uhhuh so yes we have a clear leader in
the US championship veran
akobian this is very exciting for both
of his fans in St Louis and also um
nearby I think he recent he lived in La
for a while he and his wife are in
Topeka Kansas last couple years she's
getting her law degree uh there that's
right so we've got got vuan on top of
the championship got a kky our defending
Champion just behind we got a rest day
tomorrow right and the Women's
Championship now we've got Irena crush
and it looks like Anna zatonski is going
to be right up there with her if this
game does end in a draw let's take a
quick look at that at Anna's game yeah
that definitely looked headed to a draw
as
well yes well now the position is
actually completely even material boy I
don't know if they're going to go down
to King versus King but uh what is the
times on the clocks of the players
Anna's got only about 10 seconds and um
Camila 3 minutes so maybe that's one of
the reasons that they're continuing play
here is because of the time trouble
situation although of course with a
30second increment that that can get
built up pretty quickly but 63 move game
going on here in an zon's game against
Sky day and I am amazed that Camila
hasn't just collapsed because as we
heard Alisa say that uh she they played
103 moves 111 moves 11 wow wow so Camila
really really putting in in the extra
hours in these last few rounds that's
right she's going to be very happy to
have the rest day maybe she play a Arena
and Alissa with the massage idea get a
little
relaxation before they have to get right
back into the ring on Friday exactly so
yes I should mentioned we will be back
Friday but tomorrow we're also going to
be having some fun we're going to be
doing an event Outreach get Girl Scouts
involved at the Ballpark Village and
then on the evening we're going to be at
the world chest Hall of Fame doing
reunion and this evening we're going to
uh St Louis Cardinals baseball game game
was cancelled what rained what
apparently that's what I heard what
Maurice wasn't going to throw out the
Maurice is going to miss an opportunity
to throw out the first pitch in the
Cardinal game I thought it was I think I
would have been shot at with my Yankee
hat on cuz I would have been wearing
dress blues for sure thin Stripes that's
right well let's get a final thought
from H Grandmaster Maurice Ashley as we
for
sure wait for verian I believe have a
kobean arm so forget about the final
thought this guy played a great
game let's just jump back to that
position this is dominant chess this
he's played Four he played Four draws
people were making jokes jokes they said
he's going after the half a Bobby Fisher
prize guess what he's making a run three
wins in a row he's looking really good
right now and uh I think he's got got
great chances to win the whole
thing and certainly why not I mean after
all he goes into the tournament as uh
one of the top players in the event top
players in the field he's played
excellent chess um winning today with
black is always a bonus I don't know how
how many whites does he have in his
remaining games well he's going to be
white against aronburg in round eight
that's nice and then in round nine he is
going to be black against Shanklin not
as nice but he got to alternate and then
he'll be white against KY in the pen
alternate game wow so that'll be fun and
finally finishing up the tournament with
black against Lenderman so he's got a
tough road ahead a lot of strong
opponents but of course the entire US
championships really tough a lot of a
lot of tightness there not the Women's
Championship you have a bigger gap
between the top players and the weaker
players so their lineups is even more
relevant but still it sounds like that
penultimate round is going to be a barn
burner I me right because we're going to
have Irena Crush playing against Zony
and we're gonna have kky playing against
kovan so and the number one and number
two at this moment in time and kobian is
coming into the studios I believe yeah I
think being set up um we just got one
game going just just the hon SK game
which uh now on a very very very good
day if
Camila uh
were Black's
King slightly animating night oh pardon
me uh what do we have now we have rook
and pawn versus Rick and N okay let me
just uh so Rick and Knight versus Rook
of course is a draw sometimes
the copy
oh so I was I was about to say on a very
very very good day Anna might be able to
achieve Rook a knight versus King and
Rook which is a draw um Bobby fiser F
Bobby fiser um Gary casparo famously
defeated um Judith Judith par pogar in
that ending because it was a rapid chess
event I believe that it was that he won
but uh principally this uh is a draw but
I was amazed that she was able to
achieve it I don't think Camila had to
jump into uh the situation and Anna is
probably very happy that she can torture
her for several
um can you IM I'm not going to say dozen
moves but we'll just see can you imagine
if uh they play 200 moves in total I
know and poor Camila I mean again coming
back from 111 move game of the night
before that's really really tough but at
least she saved it yes she did she was
on the the lower end of that and we have
a leader in the US Chess Championship
veran aobi and it's a new leader and he
is with Maurice a new clear leader new
clear leader and he is with Maurice
Ashley to talk about his amazing run
three wins in a
row indeed Jen with varujan akobian
grandmas and playing like a maestro now
after four draws people were joking that
maybe you're going to try to draw the
rest of your games but youve proven the
them wrong showing your fighting Spirit
you won three in a row how does it feel
uh feels great um I really like the way
I played today I thought it was just
equal position Ray played a little bit
inaccurately and I took advantage of it
there's Bishop H3 Knight G5 so I think I
played a good game you have played Ray a
lot of times last four games I found in
the database he had white every single
time in the fifth game he had white what
were your thoughts going in seeing him
get white yet again white was uh it's
okay but the surprise came with the
first move right he played the move d4
on you what was that about it was just
complete surprise for me I spent a lot
of hours preparing against E4 but uh
okay it surprised me but I think uh you
know E4 is more like I think his style
of position he gets so I I felt very
comfortable in the opening and then he
was equal then I think he tried some
tactical ideas maybe to go Bishop H3 9
G5 to sacrifice but I don't think it
worked and perhaps he missed a very
strong move Knight f8 after which I
protect all the tactics and actually I'm
winning a pawn because next move is H6
and he needs to go back and I take on F3
was very now it wasn't easy to convert
this extra Pawn because of two Bishops
but once I provoked G4 exchange the
darks for Bishops it was over make it
sound like it just a simple Technique we
know it was a terrific fight um you he's
beaten you recently I mean you you must
have felt that he was a dangerous
opponent yeah he is a dangerous opponent
we went back and forth last couple of
years you know but he's a very very
strong opponent with white is's very
dangerous
you're in first by yourself all of a
sudden Lenderman lost uh it seems like
they're going to be two the draw in the
G game I believe it's already a draw in
fact what are you what's your feeling
right now you're sitting in first place
in the US Championship yeah I'm glad to
win a game before the rest day and you
know four more rounds to go and uh it's
you cannot relax you can only relax
after the last game so at this point
just have to stay focused continue play
well you're going to have some tough
games games uh ahead you still got
kamsky to play you still have Lenderman
to play do you put those thoughts in
your head or or do you take it one game
at a time no at this point I'm just
thinking about my next opponent Arenberg
so after that we'll see next have you
played arberg before I've played him a
couple of times yes and the results uh
we had a lot of draws lately I think I
won one game in 2006 so plus one indeed
uh what are your plans for tomorrow the
ladies said that two of the ladies said
they might get massages uh to relax
what's your plan uh yeah I don't have
any plans yet I'll you know talk to my
friend you know here Gabriel and we'll
see you know but I think we'll probably
spend a lot of time preparing because it
seems like we always run out of time you
know like we prepare a lot and at the
end it's like time to go and play so we
still have things to look so no
relaxation for the weary we'll probably
do something fun but not too long maybe
a few hours all right well
congratulations on your win today and
keep up your fine play thanks Grand
Master of aruan aob on in clear first
our leader after seven rounds in the US
championships back to you we've got one
question from our audience here for aian
um they ask a bron asks a Cobian has
better results with black up to now in
the championship doesn't he um ask if
he's one of the few players who prefer
playing Black it was a good day for
black wasn't it it was a good day ver
how do you feel about the black pieces
black has been good to you in this
tournament yeah it's been good I mean
I'm actually you know I have better
score with the white pieces but in this
tournament I've had two wins I'm very
happy to win with winning with black is
very very important in this kind of
tournament because it gives you an
advantage because next game you have
white so you can try a little bit also
so winning with black is very important
I remember a book Black is okay by
andras adorian and uh vuan is definitely
making it look that way okay so you get
black in your next four games
right he doesn't like that especially
not against G well you know in chess
black is one of the best colors to have
there you go there you go so Anna and um
Camila still struggling away in a drawn
ending and I think that we'll most
likely see
um uh the two players Anna and aren tie
for first but it's very easy
for uh the defending side to um fall
into lines that are losing
um so I would what what what percentage
would you give Anna would you give her a
55% or 60 55% chance to win the game you
think sure really that's
high Rook a KN versus Rook it's I I'm
yeah oh 6% oh I'm saying 55% for sure
the question is as it the 60% we're
humans yeah camil's been been been tired
she's playing really really really hard
games and she's been on the defense for
the last three hours that that can wear
you down that's right um but uh both
players kind of not with a lot of time
so you don't think she has
51% I think she's got a chance I just
think think 60% sounded High to me but
what do you think
Maurice well I think this is an
interesting moment uh to evaluate the
the in idea right um because there is an
argument that with increments we could
keep playing and uh black could defend
this position really well not fall into
any traps you get that extra 30 seconds
so you can calculate even more and
defend yourself properly the flip side
is White's also getting those 30 seconds
all the time so instead of just
accepting a draw white could say uhuh
I'm not taking any draws because I'm
always going to get 30 seconds so I can
torture you for a long time I can build
up time on the clock and just keep
letting the game go and go and go so
it's it's a touch and go argument in
this situation personally it seems to me
that black should be able to draw this
game without too much effort but there
are tricks still and in time pressure
any kind of trick could happen but as
long as she keeps her head and it looks
like she's pretty confident right now I
think Camila will save the game that
said she's had a bad experience so far
in the tournament so maybe zon is going
to try to milk that situation
and see if she can find that blunder
right now because she would take first
place in the Championships clear first
in the champ in the women's
championships that's right so we are um
expecting uh draws going to happen a lot
of the time here and there's going to be
a tie up top at the US Women's Chess
Championship but one thing's for sure
we've got a leader in the US Chess
Championship veran aian um he he's all
smiles he's uh ahead by half a point his
nearest rival defend defending
Championship defending Champion got
kamsky um and they do still get the play
so that's a great shot for G and then
right behind them we've got a bunch of
players Lenderman on a downswing fidell
on an upswing the young nitzki also on
an upswing and Ona shook just remaining
solid and getting a jab in here and
there and meanwhile in the women's we've
got Arena Crush in the lead most likely
unless Anna manages to win this game in
which case
she would catapult into clear first
otherwise it'll be a tie between the two
of them and we'll of course look for
their penultimate battle so don't forget
guys we're not going to be around
tomorrow so you're going to want to tune
in on Friday at the usual time it was
wonderful being with you guys today this
was an awesome round and they just keep
getting more exciting so stay with us oh
absolutely and that penultimate round is
just going to be great that's right
great so I'm Jennifer shahadi and I'm
here at the C capital of Chess in
America and I'm signing off for
Grandmasters yaser Saran and Maurice
Ashley we will see you in a couple of
days
good